I have a coworker who is uh a dumbass
sometimes he'll sneak in little pranks
like
he'll print out the pages that I need
but every other page will say these nuts
on it like stuff no way is just funny
stuff the problem is I work in emergency
client services for people who have HIV
predominantly clients are usually
getting evicted
they're my God was like please the
police are trying to kick me out I'm
just trying to finish my last course of
chemo and he's like hey what do you
think of this and he shows you his phone
it's his penis these awes how do I
confront my coworker about not
going one thing right off the top of my
head give him AIDS y there there it is
he wants to last about it yeah